why would I buy this from you when I can
get this on Pinterest for free people
like things that are that are assembled
for them and in this case it's a
physical product and yes you can
download them for free but you can't
have them in your hands for free it's
tangible the more we've leared about the
algorithm the more we've realized
YouTube doesn't punish you but trying
something new it's actually very freeing
to have your own products and to be able
to rely on that because then we can make
videos based on what we want to do and
what serves the audience rather than
what the sponsors want us to
so how can content creators transition
into physical products and potentially
generate millions of dollars in this
episode I'm super fired up to be hanging
out with my friend Sarah Renee Clark
who's all the way here from Australia
and she's going to be sharing YouTube
tips of how she's gained over 200,000
subscribers powerful tips on building a
community how to build a powerful brand
and then also the most granular details
you'll probably ever get anywhere on
YouTube or the internet of about going
from digital products to physical
products Lessons Learned and so no
matter where you are in your journey I
encourage you buckle your seat belt and
watch to the end of this one because
this is going to be a power packed
episode of the think media podcast Sarah
welcome to the show thank you so much
for having me I'm excited and so for
those that are just meeting you you've
got 266,000 plus subscribers on YouTube
You're transforming coloring pages into
epic art coloring books artist Channel
very really really cool stuff but tell
us your story when did you start YouTube
and uh how did you get where you are
today yeah well I've actually only been
on YouTube for about 2 and a half years
um everything else that we're sort of
going to talk about today goes a little
bit back further so I I started making
coloring books actually um when I had my
first son I was looking for something
creative to do um as a bit of an outlet
you know new mom um didn't want to go
back to work so I was trying to find
something to make money so I didn't have
to go back to my job um and so I started
making coloring books and coloring books
for me was actually something that I
didn't have to do the coloring I could
draw in black and white and everyone
else could do the coloring so that
worked for me although as soon as I
started doing it and it became an
opportunity to talk to people and people
wanted help with coloring so I had to
learn that side of it and it became an
opportunity to teach it became an
opportunity for me to be creative in
other ways and the marketing side of it
actually became for me more addictive
than the art itself which eventually
over years became YouTube it became
Facebook it became products and it
became everything that we do now when
did you upload your first video about 2
and 1/ half years ago it was September I
think 2021 I don't know if I'm doing
that math right but yeah and you are
living in Australia yes you got a family
yes couple kids two kids and you upload
your first video how did you create it
so we we actually started doing videos
not on YouTube we did a few to put on
our blog before we realized the power of
YouTube um so my YouTube channel
actually is like it started in 2016 but
we didn't sort of start a channel
officially um the first few videos were
just like here's a tutorial and so
they're much older and they were filmed
with all kinds of not tripods as tripods
so um I think we had like a mic stand
hooked up with a webcam attached to it
with like a bulldog clip and all kinds
of WID things and that were just
tutorials to just be a video embedded in
our blog so that was how we started and
then when we officially wanted to start
we said we're going to do a weekly
episode on YouTube and we set up an
introduction our desk and I think after
about 2 or 3 weeks we sort of fell in
love with YouTube and then went okay
actually I think we're YouTubers now and
we're going to do this properly and so
we then started working on actually
building out our studio and it has kind
of taken over our lives in our house
since and now we our studio I mean we
recently did a studio tour on our
Channel a lot of people look at our
studio now and kind of go oh is that
what it takes to be YouTu no we just
really like what we do so it's really
evolved but you started like we all at
zero started messy eventually 3 years
ago you were making videos uh how to
color your digital planner or coloring
tutorials using highlighters and a pen
tell me about this video though coloring
through cancer that I was actually
uploaded six years ago yeah so that was
again that was back when we were sort of
doing blogging and at that point we'd
made a few just coloring books like
there were products it was long before
we sort of officially started our
YouTube channel which is the bottom
video you're looking at on that one
there so one of the ways that we doing
marketing was when I made a coloring
book we'd make a little promo video for
The Coloring book um so that particular
book my mom went through um terminal
cancer she passed away three or four
years ago now uh from breast cancer and
when she was sick I used to take
coloring books in with her through
chemotherapy and I thought it'd be
really nice if she could color something
that was like encouraging as well um and
so she actually helped me to come up
with some sayings that were really
encouraging and I turned them into
coloring pages and that book now we
actually have completely free to
download on our website because it for
me was a really special book that was
like a tribute to her and so we make it
free and we often um we have hospitals
contact us and they want a copy and we
try to get them physical copies as well
like it's kind of just something special
that we just want to give to the world
in that particular book yeah so it's
kind of a special one that's a part of
my history and my journey but it's also
six years old now so I'd actually love
to redo it at some point and make it
higher quality again but yeah yeah well
I'm sorry for your loss and thank you
for sharing that but that just speaks to
how powerful what you're doing is and
how powerful obviously coloring can be
fun but the impact we always talk about
we want to help purpose-driven people
and just the impact of your creativity
and your art the things people could be
going through and the therapy of what it
is color color therapy I suppose is an
actual thing in and of itself so this is
powerful now I do want to talk about we
literally have if you're on the audio
version version you should rewatch the
video version on YouTube because I'm
pumped because there's a lot of
different physical products you have
here that we'll talk about we've got um
journals that are coming out this color
block and we'll learn more about that uh
coloring planners and some digital
things but I I do want to talk about
some YouTube tips and strategies what
are some lessons that you've learned um
as you have grown over 200,000
subscribers and from videos that work
the best performing videos that we could
learn from to if we want to get more
views reach more people what are some
lessons you've learned yeah I think when
I first started my channel I was very
tutorial focused um and as we've grown
and part of this is a personality thing
as well it was sort of what we enjoyed
but I definitely found that my channel
saw a lot more growth when I shifted
away from focusing on search and
focusing on tutorials and instead
focused more on entertainment and
created titles I guess that were less
keyword focused and more focused on what
people would want to click on and
because I really want to teach and I
really want to help people learn I still
build the tutorials in if you watch even
my most recent videos they're full of
tips they're full of um trying to
inspire people and a lot of them are
full of information all throughout but
they're not presented as a tutorial and
so we still hide that stuff all
throughout and a lot of our videos we
still try and even write a blog post on
my website where we do the more tutorial
based stuff there but in just reframing
them and building them as more of an
entertainment thing in the first place
we're now getting a million views on
some of our videos even though we don't
have anywhere near a million subscribers
whereas in the past we were getting more
like 20,000 views and that's probably
the biggest thing that we've done um
it's allowed people to more I guess get
to know me and get to know my
personality rather than only watching
the videos when they're looking for a
specific topic that's powerful and it
does seem like you're doing the
challenge strategy meaning um coloring
using only green
pencils it's like a challenge you put
put constraints around it the thumbnail
is also brilliant and you got 631 th000
views great Point that's three times the
amount of subscribers your channel has
and then your second most powerful video
is 1.7 million I tested every color
pencil in the world and especially for
kind of viral videos Extremes in the
world is is a good one like your thing
in the world every it's Quite a feat and
then also a brilliant thumbnail
where all these different color pencils
are around you it's amazing
4,132 pencils kind of that challenge
that extreme that I've got to click on
that and then watch pretty powerful and
that's a 28 minute video yeah I think um
we were really surprised when we first
tried to shorten our videos because we
used to do 40-minute videos and we tried
to get down to like even 10 minutes but
now I've actually found that stretching
them back more towards the 20 minutes is
actually better fit for us our audience
seems to like 15 to 20 minute videos and
I think that's just different for
everyone I think that's just a case of
experimenting and really finding what
works for your audience and knowing who
your audience is and for us the shorter
videos just don't give us the time that
we need but I think the biggest thing
that I've always tried to do even with
those things that maybe sound a bit more
click baity if you're just hearing them
now um is that when I said I tested
every single pencil I searched the
internet we we visited America a year
ago and I hunted down every pencil I
could find and if there was a brand that
I could get my hands on we bought it
there were over 90 different brands
tested in that video and when I was
reading the comments people were like
you missed this brand I was genuinely
disappointed because we tried to
literally find every single brand it
wasn't just a gimmick I tried to be true
to my word in that if we say we are
testing every we are testing every and
we did 18 different test points and we
made sure it was thorough and then after
we tested everything we also provided
people on my website with like an
incredibly detailed breakdown so that
again the video wasn't just entertaining
it was also useful so someone actually
wants to find what is the best pencils
to buy in this topic they could go to
our website and there is so much
information that it's like you never
need to go anywhere else to find that
answer and that was kind of our goal
with that video is like we want to give
people so much information and then
break it down that we can be that
resource and we can be that place so
that they can get all their answers from
us and I'm wondering if you know off the
top of your head how much ad Revenue
that video end you uh earned you or just
roughly 1.7 million views I'm just
curious because you invested a ton of
time also money but I would imagine that
you've got affiliate links to pencils
that do have affiliate programs plus the
ad Revenue do you have any idea I'll be
honest I don't look at ad Revenue yeah
um our ad Revenue only makes up 2% of
our business Revenue yeah so I don't
look at it um I've also had people ask
me like what's your RPM's average I'm
like I couldn't even give you a bup
because I don't look at those numbers um
it's just one of those things where I
guess for us like I don't want I mean
it's it's not it's easy to say that when
it's not our big Focus but I also don't
ever want to make videos based on sure
what performs based on that even our
sponsors it's like I don't want to agree
to sponsors based on the money y it's
actually very freeing to have your own
products and to be able to rely on that
because then we can make videos based on
what we want to do and what serves the
audience rather than what the sponsors
want us to do andly that's been
wonderful and that's you sharing your
absolute truth which reinforces the
message of this video as well as we talk
about um products here in a bit but
let's go a little bit deeper on your
YouTube channel tactics you've already
dropped many nuggets you're leaning into
shorts how often how seriously are you
taking them so shorts say something that
I came into very unwillingly at first
um but I think the more that we are
looking at it and the more that we've
seen YouTube really putting in the
effort to actually make sure that shorts
are done properly for everyone the more
now that we are seeing that we need to
lean into shorts um and now I'm actually
excited about the potential because I
think my biggest concern initially is
that when I saw shorts I thought of Tik
Tok and I thought of the parts about
shorts and Tik Tok that I don't like um
I deleted Tik Tok off my phone recently
because I am not that audience Myself
and I struggled to I guess reconcile the
parts of Tik Tok and that that I don't
like and I guess the the dishonest
shorts that sort of trick you into
watching versus the kind of business
that I want to have and the kind of
Channel that I want to have and the kind
of people I want to attract and I really
struggled with that for a while because
I didn't want to change my style to fit
this format but I think now we've
finally started to be able to see enough
examples and enough other people succeed
that we're starting to come with ideas
that can fit our format that attract the
kind of people that I think will like
our main Channel content that it's
giving us a bit more confidence in
experimenting with that too um so we
we've had a few that have got a few
million views which is really good but
then we have a lot that aren't getting
those views but it's at least not
scaring us off and so we are trying more
things like the tutorials that we're no
longer doing in our main videos because
they do seem to really work for us in
our shorts and I actually really enjoyed
um John Us's approach to shorts and he
talked about it a little bit at VidCon
that we just attended about treating it
like a bit bit of a variety show and I
thought that's something that I'd like
to have a go at and it's something that
we're brainstorming at the moment so
we've actually just come from the M&M
shop in uh Vegas and we thought what can
we do here that would be shorts cuz it
was so colorful so we pulled out one of
our products which is the color Cube
which we'll talk about soon and we
didn't have the cube on me but I had the
app on my or the uh PDF on my phone and
I pulled pulled out a color swatch and
said Can I stack some M&M's and create
my own custom selection based on the
colors of one of the color swatches and
so we did and so we're going to try that
as a short and see how it goes because
that's something completely different
but it's using our product in a
completely bizarre scenario and it's
very colorful and so we thought that's
something different but that's something
exciting and let's just experiment um I
think on YouTube we used to be really
scared of experimenting and I think the
more we've learned about the algorithm
the more we've realized YouTube doesn't
punish you for trying something new like
that for us has been really liberating
um and shorts especially that we
actually can try new things and your
next video is not going to be punished
if your last video doesn't do well and I
think that's been the biggest thing for
us in just taking a breath and going
it's okay to try something it's okay if
it fails you just don't do it twice or
you know even even do it twice and if it
keeps failing then throw it away and
then try something new because you never
know if that idea might just be the
thing that launches a whole new series
that might be the very thing that takes
your channels on wi you yeah and Renee
Richie we recently had him on uh from
YouTube and he reinforced that point if
you upload a video that just completely
tanks does it ruin your channel does it
ruin the algorithm from YouTube
themselves they've said no it doesn't um
and so your encouragement to experiment
is great and your encouragement about
how you felt about shorts initial is
like what we see in our community
consistently people like I don't want to
do them they're going to ruin YouTube
you know I don't like them it's not my
vibe but you've shared some very
powerful insights about maybe
experimenting maybe do a variety show
and um I recommend of course we'll
Circle back a couple times that you can
look at the show notes check out Sarah's
Channel because you could see how she's
evolving in shorts and how that might
relate to your own channel and strategy
well let's talk a little bit about
moneti ization I want to get two
physical products but what are your
income streams you said ad revenue is
just 2% what are what are kind of the
rough percentages and the different
income streams yeah so uh that's about
2% and then within that so well straight
up 95% is products yeah physical
products or digital no physical and
digital um so we do sell both and then
the rest so you've got 2% is AdSense and
then that last 3% is mix of affiliate
Revenue uh sponsors so that's people
sponsoring our videos on YouTube which
we don't ask for often because we have
our own products and basically any other
little bits that come from other sources
as well um so I mean there's there's
always lots and lots of little other
things but yeah all of it comes into
that last little percent so products is
our biggest thing gotcha and for example
this is one of your most popular
products and if you're on audio I'm
holding a color Cube that is a cardboard
uh really nice well produced Cube I'm
taking the top off and it's color Cube
volume one by Sarah Renee Clark and
inside are these kind of color
swatches and this one product has
generated $2 million yes break it down
tell us the story so this actually
started as a digital product and when
I've had people ask like how do we make
something like this I'm like the reason
that we had the confidence in this and
the confidence to make this was because
we kind of had the proof of concept from
the digital product sales so the digital
version of this which was a PDF booklet
of color palettes we' sold 20,000 of
them in the four years prior to our
audience and the biggest thing our
audience kept saying was I want this in
a book I want to hold it in my hands and
it was from all of that feedback because
we do listen to our audience a lot that
we eventually said all right let's turn
it into a physical product and in the
first two days two days of the pre-sale
so we didn't even have it in our hands
yet in just the first two or 3 days we
made
$50,000 in Revenue in the pre-sales cuz
people were so excited and we had to
ring our manufacturer and say we're
going to have to up the order because
we'd only ordered 6,000 in the first run
um this was July last year so this is
only well basically 12 months from today
and as of today we've sold 30,000 of
these that is wild now one of the myths
or mindsets people have is well if I
give away free information on YouTube
why would somebody buy a course if I
give away the product for free why would
somebody pay for it so tell us this
story didn't the version 1.0 of this was
actually given away for free actually
every single card in here so every
single one of these pets is available on
my Instagram for free it is available on
Pinterest for free and it's available on
our blog all for free and our biggest
competitors with this and it's funny
because people remind us of this in our
Facebook ads cuz we run Facebook ads to
a cold audience for these which also
converts really well by the way because
it's not because it's not a product
about us it's a product about our
audience which is like a whole another
it's a whole another topic right there
um but people remind us all the time why
would I buy this from you when I can get
this on Pinterest for free because you
can get color palettes and I'll be
honest when we first were selling the
digital version I was asking the same
thing I'm like I don't know why people
keep buying this because it's free on
the internet already I don't get it but
people like things that are that are
assembled for them yes um and in this
case it's a physical product and yes you
can download them for free but you can't
have them in your hands for free it's
tangible people love having something
tangible and it's actually not about me
because like I just said we we sell this
to complete strangers it's completely
disassociated from my name so it's not
dependent on my audience because we're
not just selling it to my fans that
helps for sure but a lot of people buy
this and then find out who I am and then
they start like this is the first step
into our ecosystem for a lot of people
and then they discover me on YouTube
which is opposite to how a lot of things
happen yeah and that speaks to if
there's listening to this you know what
is your million-dollar product idea
that's not just a t-shirt with your
YouTube channel logo on it that's
probably not going to be it it's it's
something that is transcendent something
that's bigger than you something that
has utility and it's an interesting test
you brought up would somebody be
interested in that product cold and for
if you're new to kind of marketing terms
that just means they're unaware of you
warm traffic would be they know you so
they're like there's that's going to be
easier to sell something to warm traffic
because they trust you where it's cold
they don't know anything about you we've
all seen it we're scrolling on Instagram
that user is expressed that they're
maybe into art they're into something
and this is shown to them and they go oh
that's cool and they buy it so you're
saying people that don't even know you
they've never watched the YouTube
channel are interested in that product
you definitely know you have a good
product if that happens but I also want
to Circle back to the fact that had you
listen to one or two comments that's
like oh you can get this for free well
that person's not going to buy it but
you've done $2 million in sales so the
truth is your Instagram posts and your
Pinterest posts those have been consumed
and a lot of people have gotten free
value and people have also bought the
digital product version of this you're
saying it's just a PDF yeah and it's
just all in one place and we sold 20,000
of that before this even existed so then
you stepped into digital which is also a
good linear lesson for somebody wanting
to growth hack or scale a business maybe
stepping fullon into this is a also high
production value these are really well
made I mean the other thing with this is
especially for us we we have never done
anything in our business on credit so
digital products is also very very good
way to start for that reason because
other than like making a website which
we don't use Shopify we do it ourselves
but that's partly because I have an
amazing husband who knows how to do that
maybe not the best option for if you
don't have the skill set totally but
there was no cost for us like for every
order you have a few fees transaction
fees but you don't have any production
cost whereas when we did this we had to
take a chance on this especially
pre-sales doeses help with that but
generally speaking you have to spend
money up front before you have money so
I think I'll I'll look to Shane to nod
if I'm right on not but I think this
cost us 150,000 for our first print run
up front yeah save money by the amount
of units you do yes it drives down cost
per un a small run because then you're
just losing money well so you bet big
going into it yes but only because we
were confident that we knew this was a I
I wouldn't recommend doing that for your
first product in fact our other product
that we have being the planner the first
print run we did was much smaller the
catch with that is the first year we did
that we didn't make a profit we broke
even and it's taken us 3 years on that
product to make
a profit but that's also because that's
a dated product so you don't want to
have stock sitting around at the end of
the year it's worth nothing that's a
good point so you'd want to sell out
because the planner and even to a
certain point in the year no one's going
the year is too far gone so there's like
what is the window of time on an actual
planner we so most plan you'll see in
shops calendars and stuff most of them
go half price in January like as soon as
January first hits they're all half
price we managed to get um ours at least
till February before we start dropping
the price and we've actually had buy
them even four months into the year
because it is a more Niche item and
because we are a Creator I think
creators do because you do have fans and
you do have a bit of that I guess those
things that allow you to sell your face
on a t-shirt or your name on a t-shirt
there are those connections that you
will have people that will buy from you
because of who you are that they won't
buy from Target in that same time period
so there are certain elements that we
have as creators that people will buy
and it extends that period but on the
other hand we also have people already
asking us for the 2024 planner in June
the previous year so we've um got the
Prototype here for 2024 and we already
have people asking us if they can buy it
now but um we are going to try and open
the pre-sales for it soon and hopefully
get it out to people soon and at the
time of recording it's not even July so
you're you are really hustling in ah
head but that's also is that normal so
this is actually um it's this is on time
for us to have this now we need to get
them like into print in the next two
weeks because there's also times with
manufacturing where if we get this to
the manufacturers in the next two weeks
we'll have them in our audience's hand
by October because of the delays with
Printing and Manufacturing and then
shipping and then that gives us about
two weeks to get them out to everyone by
October um one year Unfortunately they
all got held up at the ships at the docs
in America and some of our customers
were getting them in December and some
of our International customers got them
in January and we had to refund a lot of
people and we took losses on those
orders So Physical products does come
with a lot of risks and depending on how
much you want to look after your
customers we actually also have a staff
member full-time now who just answers
customer emails and fan emails and
that's something a lot of people just
wouldn't be prepared to do so for us
having a product-based business does
come with other expenses that a lot of
creators are probably like whoa I didn't
know that was what it takes but for us
like Integrity is a big part of our
business buiness looking after our
community is a big part of our business
we make a point of answering every email
that comes into our inbox from fans
whether it's just a nice hello I want to
say hi to Sarah or whether it's um a
customer inquiry we try to get back to
them allall within like 2 days and I
know that that's not normal but that's
we we want our business to be about
people and that matters to us and so we
do these things but that does come at a
cost but when you want a business to be
product based and that matters like
we've put the money into that and it's
working for us obviously so yeah that's
that's really inspiring and it's cool I
I love to kind of break it because this
all could seem of course overwhelming if
you're just starting and it's a lot of
moving pieces but I love that you built
up to it blog came before YouTube yes
for how many years about four years I
think okay and so you're adding value in
these different places and then you were
you were leaning into these products
needing to it also speaks to listeners
why you need a big enough business in
terms of Reven Vue because you never
know what's going behind the scenes of
course $2 million is extraordinary
regardless and $2 million is impressive
but also sometimes people hear $2
million and they're like oh you just got
$2 million like cash and you're like
actually there's going to be taxes and
then there's also the hard cost of the
products themselves so there's the
margin and then there's the team that we
have supporting it and then we have just
the Practical things and then we have
that this product did well but we needed
to do some refunds over here because of
that and it reminds me of one of my
favorite quotes from a mentor he says
scared money don't make money and
there's just something about being on
offense and Business and
Entrepreneurship and YouTube where you
you've tested a lot of different things
you you you're not moving in fear but
you're taking action and it's okay if
one thing loses especially if you have a
big enough business that another product
could make up for that one of the things
I want you to go a little bit deeper on
though is these products came out of a
response to listening to your community
it it's clear and evident that you are
incredibly passionate about caring for
your community you've you've staffed
someone to respond talk about your
approach to building Community we had an
episode with shelene Johnson who said
that basically her opinion she thought
the future of social media is community
period that as people are just cutting
up people's content and putting it
elsewhere why there's just lots of
there's faceless channels there's
automation channels that is cool can
also get a little overhyped um and then
there's also just practical call it
search based content or even suggested
content but if nobody makes a connection
with you then where does it really go
and even if you have a viral video but
there's no Community then what do you
really have so it's power talk about how
you've been intentional about building a
community and maybe some tips for
somebody that's starting and they were
just thinking about making videos that
could maybe be thinking about building a
community yeah it's actually something
that we talk about a lot because it's
something that's a lot easier when
you're smaller as well and as your
audience grows the more you're connected
with your community there are also
problems that arise as that grows like
you accidentally create parasocial
relationships that sometimes mean you
have to put up new boundaries but new
boundaries also mean creating more
distance in your community and so we've
had some of these things happen but
we're constantly navigating it because I
often talk to my team and go great so
how do we create that boundary and how
do we also give me my time back because
that's the biggest thing is that I
started doing all this myself but the
more projects we do the more I need my
time back more than anyone in our team
but at the same time I want to be about
the community more than anything so the
few things that we do have set up is
like we have a Facebook group that we
invite people in and I can't be as
active in it as I want to be but I try
to be in there at least once a week
commenting and it's like I have that on
my to-do list of like no matter how busy
I get try to jump in there once a week
um and we even talked about recently
that I have moderators in there but I'm
like I'm not connected enough to them so
my head moderator who's on our staff I
said to her okay we actually need to
like jump on a zoom call and just hang
out with them with me it's not something
we've done they might even listen to
this and go oh cool cuz I don't we
haven't even talked about it with them
yet but I'm like I need to actively
invest time in them because if I don't
have that much time to pour into
everybody I need to at least pour into
the people that are pouring into the
rest of the people so that's something
that we've prioritized and said we need
to get that right because if I can't
look after the thousands I need to at
least look after the 10 that are looking
after the thousands better um we have
actually turned off uh like DMS on
Instagram and Facebook and stuff in
order to funnel those people to our
email because we have the email system
figured out and we can't well monitor
all these other connections so we have
them all just telling people email us
because we have um one of our team
members that really doesn't good job of
looking after the email and she does it
really well and I can't read all those
emails but she does have a thing where a
fan send emails she copies them to a
spreadsheet so that I can still read
them so when she tells people she's
passed them on to me she's not lying she
has passed them on to me and I can read
them and if it's something she feels
like I should answer she does let me
know so we still try to keep me
connected we don't have to but again
it's that Integrity thing it's about
making sure that we are about people um
and even with YouTube it's like I still
do want to read the the comments so
we're actually looking at like what
software exists there's a new program
called glisten I don't know if you've
heard about it that's coming out and
I've been talking with the founders of
that and actually looking at um it's all
about using AI to better engage with
your community and to work out how to
use that so I'm looking at okay can we
get in on the ground level with that and
actually even talk to them about making
sure that not only is that built right
but can we use it for our community
before we outgrow the community and
because yeah the bigger you get the
harder it is to keep on top of comments
so we're looking now at how can we
actually get involved in that and manage
those comments but I think the biggest
thing too with our videos that we've
decided to do is As on our main Channel
we get more I guess more entertainment
more big video focused we've actually
started doing vlogging again on our
second channel to give people a better
chance to have that personal connection
with me because we felt like we lost
that a bit on the main Channel and so
we've actually said let's bring back
Vlogs um even we're going to try and do
some more live streams because live
streams you do get more time to have
that personal connection so it's not
something we're doing now but we're like
let's bring it back this year so it's
something that we're constantly thinking
about and we're like let's not lose
touch and it's a big priority for us I
really love your heart for integrity in
your community and one of the things I
want to highlight is majority probably
listening to this aren't thinking about
like hiring a complete staff to manage
their Community but a mistake I've seen
of successful creators and my vision for
the fake media podcast is some
successful creators that start doing
well what they actually do is they kind
of get greedy and instead of investing
profits back into the business and back
into the community they just try to take
as much as they can off the top at some
point you you you do have less time but
the absolute smart move is if you could
put people there to care for them you
said caring for the 10 that care for the
thousands is what we're trying to do at
think media as well and then create of
course other opportunities unfortunately
there's too many stories of people who
again don't put their heart into the
product or into the customer service or
into the community don't put their money
there they just kind of launch something
but then the product end up ends up not
being very good the support ends up not
being very good so you're really doing
it right and that is incredibly
inspiring and I hope even if you're at
the ground floor I would encourage
everybody listening to this to think
about reinvesting profits constantly
back in the business to just love people
more serve people more because the
inevitable result to will be more
profits but it also just might be a
slower timeline and it's patience it's
Legacy over currency and it's just
patience of and also impact over income
ultimately and so very powerful and the
idea of bringing back a second Channel
we warn people against that actually
because you could your focus can get
divided but key word you said you have a
team are you editing the Vlogs yourself
or are you also Outsourcing that editing
no so we um have another editor on our
team who does help with like the first
cut of her main videos but otherwise her
job is shorts and Vlog nice and that's
like that's her baby that's her stuff
that she looks after us you and I were
both at VidCon um I guess last week and
did you Vlog there we were supposed to
We were supposed to bring her back a
video that she could edit and instead I
think we're going to be bringing her
back a bunch of b-roll and say tell me
what voice over you want the thing with
our Vlog and with our whole second
channel is that we've decided not to
worry about the stats yeah not to look
at any of that like the goal of that is
purely for like a really cool audience
and we're like it's not about growing
that channel because that's I think the
Trap is that it becomes another split
Focus um and so we're like we're not
going to set deadlines for that we're
not going to set schedules for that
because we don't have time to commit to
another to-do list um we need and even
on our main Channel we're not we're not
posting a video every week anymore we're
posting a video every second week and if
it needs to be every third week we're
letting oursel do that um and funny
enough when we're we've actually gone
three weeks instead of two those videos
have been the biggest ones which has
been interesting for us because that
sort of contradicts everything that we'd
been told beforehand but it's been
encouraging because it's taken so much
pressure off and it's given me sometimes
just an extra few days to uh let Shane
do some extra editing and give me an
extra few days to just work on some
other deadlines for the products because
at the moment we are in the middle of
trying to get the planner ready um to
get that launched in July cuz that's
when we do it every year so it's like
that extra time right now is more
important on the products this is the
time of year where that's the most
important and so we kind of just have to
juggle things because time is limited
it's the one thing you can't buy more of
yeah so we just have to do what we can
so I also want people to hear you said
that you're sometimes uploading once
every two weeks if not once every 3
weeks now of course there's a few things
you have going for you you are
established you do have some subscribers
but I think the the cool idea there is
again people can get obsessed like it
has to be a week or more than that
multiple times a week they think that
that has to do with the algorithm
YouTube's also been clear it doesn't
channels that upload less frequently can
be just as successful allows you to make
better videos but what's so powerful is
you have this incredible content creator
business but you're not on this
treadmill treadmill yeah burning you out
yeah and the more powerful thing we
always Point people this way we say it's
really it's less about your views and
subscribers it's more about your money
plan it's more about your business model
and this is also an overflow of your
passion and your talent as a team um and
everything that you guys are doing but
you have this incredible business model
because you're not dependent on feeding
the algorithm videos just to get a few
pennies and AD sense yeah but you've got
something else going in this case
digital and physical products um before
we land the plane I'm just curious you
know on your about page you do have
Instagram and Facebook and Facebook
group is a Facebook group free
yes so you got the Facebook group so you
have a Facebook page a Facebook group
you do have Tik Tok you do have
Pinterest do you have do you have a
social media manager I mean how do you
sustain all the social are you active
everywhere yeah so my way of doing all
that and actually kind of a cool thing
to my business as a whole I do actually
very much believe in only doing one
thing but the way I treat that is do one
thing until you've mastered it then
either get it systemized or get it
automated or get it outsourced and then
do the next thing Y and a lot of those
things we set up before we even did
YouTube so like I mastered I actually
set up Facebook first I got it automated
and then I jumped into Pinterest and
then I got Pinterest fully automated to
a point that I spent probably 10 minutes
on it a week sometimes I didn't open it
for months but it was just posting
itself Facebook I left for like 2 years
on an auto posting thing and it kept
growing and growing growing eventually
realized I should probably update it
because the memes were getting a bit old
but a lot of this stuff was kind of
running itself now that we do have a
team I've had my team now actually
making sure it's active because I wanted
it to be like they write the content but
because again an Integrity thing I don't
want someone else writing and pretending
to be me I still read everything before
it's post and often I end up changing
stuff because I never want something to
be posted and me saying it's me if it's
not me that wrote it or at least sort of
signed off and what was written does
slow down our process but it's kind of
the best we can do because I kind of
have that standed and I just wanted
that's just how I want to do things um
but yes someone else manages all that
but my thing's always been and it's a
big thing in how I do my time is with
every task I do first of all it's kind
of like if you don't need to do it don't
do it so we say no to a lot of things
it's kind of like if it's not like a yes
I absolutely want to do this then just
don't do it um after that it's like okay
can we automate it so it's like cut it
automate it um and then if we can
Outsource it or give it to someone else
on the team and if we can't do any of
those then I have to create a really
good system for it or even now if it is
in the team create a really good system
system for it so like we're starting to
use notion for a lot of stuff thanks to
Thomas Frank that's got me into that and
we have lots of systems in our business
we have lots of checkpoints for the team
to do stuff and we use a lot of tools to
automate stuff so all of our Facebook
posts are kind of like in loops and
stuff like that that's automated a lot
of stuff scheduled we use all the
scheduling tools for like all of these
different things we use different ones
for each two rather than all of the the
All-In-One tools which feels easier but
we've kind of found the perfect app for
each website that has the perfect
customization and we've gotten really
happy with them so slightly more
complicated but it gives us better
results but we did each of those one at
a time over a bunch of years and so now
we've kind of just got a system in place
that was a a a Matt more advanced level
master class and so I actually want to
do a couple of things I actually want to
invite uh listeners to the audio maybe
you've been listening for a while and I
know you're sitting there you're walking
your dog you're in your car but you
haven't ra and reviewed the podcast if
you're on Spotify this is your time to
rate the podcast or leave a review on
Apple I also then if you're on YouTube
that's the only place you can comment
and I would actually love to know what
other questions you have for Sarah
because I would love to have Sarah back
on the podcast especially on this whole
idea of like scaling a Creator business
of building a team how do you hire a
team how do you do this so many
different moving parts so I think it
would be cool to do a part two she'll
probably be back in Australia but we can
always jump on streamyard perfect record
and make that happen so I would love to
get your aha moments or questions you
have maybe your curio curiosity was
peaked posted in the YouTube comments
and then of course subscribe and share
if uh you listen to it there or whatever
version you listen to massive love Sarah
this has been a powerful episode we
we're going to link everything in the
show notes and you've got some really
cool things that uh if people even want
to go directly to the color Cube or
anything like that but shout people
out in regards to you got to match up
the colors I did the lid wrong and I
love it um so yeah where can people find
you and follow you shout it out and of
course everything will be linked up in
the show notes yeah so uh social media
is easy on every platform I'm Sarah
Renee Clark so and um on my website
Sarah Rene clark.com nice and easy thank
you so much for being a part of the
thank media podcast